what's the what's the penalty for losing
football to the head suppose so yeah
here we are again then great
six years later hello I'm Gavin done a
while ago down I threw a ball at your
head why apparently I've seen the video
but I don't remember it at all didn't
knock the memory clean out of every Sean
I like you boy just went on the floor
that was filmed a thousand frames a
second but today we have a camera that
will do 28,000 frames a second let's do
it again maybe you're not the memory
back into me with this one maybe as this
hits your head you'll go back in time
six years you know I'll just forget
everything since up in there we didn't
really show this in the first video but
it's not easy to get more into a
football well it takes time but just
imagine you're pumping a pump and the
air comes out you stop good sir
obviously what is thick and what is
going to run Edel nose takes takes a lot
of time
so you have to let the air out and then
show up on these needles in fill it the
water near it
it's nearly full can't let it sit in the
war it says oh you know rattle your
brain yeah oh God already this brown my
brain that's enough to the vocal full of
air okay
playing football I don't have to pull
cuz yeah I'm like why would I do that
well you lose brain cells no I'm not
doing get him that I'm like so all right
last time you went for a sort of toothy
grin it's time I reckon a flabby face
sort of gormless look and if you can
keep your eyes open that's a bonus right
critical focus
let's go
right wait to my right for a few tries
let's go site you out I found the day I
found the same found it be I just I just
imagine that you're shaking like a
maracas next for me gonna get hit it's a
bit high out that was it
I said clear on the side of the face on
the shockwave said Oh your nose bone
moved under your nose now the chakra in
your mouth weight hung behind you know
someone else who's that I don't think
I'm asleep there Oh class stayed there
with the rest of it
[Music]
crazy oh it's cloth I like it a lot
better slower it's like bloody 30
degrees area 35 degrees I need to feel
good yeah
like we've got our own pool yeah oh no I
mean people spend a lot of money on
pools but you really just don't need
just get a dustbin and get a gammy old
bin and fill it with hose-water
and it's a safe and a pump a bike cotton
wha
yeah I lost another two IQ points there
what you down to now 67 73 geez it was
fascinating slower I never thought I'd
see the nose bone move under the nose
well I saw exactly where your nose ended
where this the gristle and Charlie yeah
imagine what mine would have been like
yes the end of it with a what's
interesting is that usually when we do a
slo-mo it's like alright here comes the
ball here comes the ball now you're
getting here now you're bouncing away
with this camera it's like alright
here's the ball now you're getting here
you're still getting here
you're literally still getting hit by a
ball and it goes on forever through it's
amazing I look floppy in slow motion for
a courageous so that was 28 times slower
than the first time we did it and
hopefully in six or so years we'll be
doing it even slower than that I will
give you enough time to rebuild the IQ
it'll be doubts like 50 say do you think
each time you get hit more IQ falls out
yeah definitely hopefully you enjoyed
that revisit feel free to follow us on
Twitter give the old one I watch it was
pretty funny we got behind the scenes
channel and we've got much know whatever
you want to do at this point and we all
hope to see you in the next video see
you in seven years gonna get hit again